welcome back ladies you have been live
from pax east here in Boston I'm
Christmas panky pangas and I'm joined by
a very special guest would you like to
deduces upset yeah sure what's up guys i
am the community developer on rainbow 6
siege my name is Justin Kruger I'm so
excited to be here today yeah whoo who
else is excited yeah there you go yeah
awesome and I'm relatively new to the
project but I'm fallen in love with the
community the the feedback is amazing
this community is one of the best I've
ever been a part of so I mean I know
everyone's you wait for today you teased
it yesterday yep just like dust line
operation dust line is the season 2
operation and it as you can see for the
from the image that we released
yesterday it takes place it's a much
different setting than season one which
was cold dark and you know I mean it was
not kind of I isolated but now we're
actually going to the Middle East with
with dust line and it's and where we're
going to be actually you know much
warmer setting a much different setting
it's going to be a little bit more
chaotic so it's going to be kind of cool
okay so Middle East sandy map no snow
complete other into the victim of that
operators are no big thing everyone's
mind there's a lot of rumors floating
around we've seen some potential
pictures and images yes what can you
tell us about the operators that are
coming so I think twitch chat has been
waiting for this all day I never miss a
chance I'm excited we have for the very
first time we're going to be revealing
the actual operators and we have an
image that if you could throw that up
there they are the season two operators
so on on your left we have Valkyrie to
defense her sleeves are the coolest
things ever and with these operators
were introducing a lot of new things
first of all we're introducing a new
seat to you like these are the Navy
SEALs okay and Valkyrie she is our
defense operator and she's she's
equipped with a spas-12 and she her
gadgets are also kind of a game changer
where she has deployable sticky cameras
and so these deployable sticky cameras
you'll be able to basically throw them
to any part of the map any you know
wherever you can stick a thing can we
throw them outside yet the buildings
okay so it's kind of a game changer yeah
and you can and and anybody on your team
can actually use those those those
gadgets and for our other operator the
attacker Blackbeard he he's equipped
with a tactical armor rifle shield so
he's a very aggressive point man and
it's really cool gadget um but yeah
that's those are our season two
operators he also had a 50 Cal in his
hand in that picture does we yo digo the
new 22 new operators are introducing the
desert eagle into the game very nice
alright when of course is the question
on everyone's lips when are we going to
see these two new absolutely everybody's
been asking when and you'll be able to
get these operators for season pass
holders starting the week of May ninth
so we can may not you'll be able to get
these operators I know a lot of you may
have thought April but due to the shift
in release schedule of black ice we've
had
equal [ __ ] future operations but our
objective was always three months every
three months you get some new content
new operators and a map so it may not be
April we still on schedule still people
absolutely yeah that is very important
on during the pc finals at if live from
cologne on may seven you will get a live
demo of season two and would play on
stage at at the ESL pc finals in cologne
nice all right lots of new contents of a
pc photos in porto thank you very much
justice those you guys we've still got a
final coming up excellent versus elevate
North America versus North America right
after this one more short break don't go
there guys thank you very much again and
I'll see you in just a moment thanks